guys I'm back it's a daily rapid arena
going on right now but there's only
three minutes left to determine I'm
going to join and we'll see if it
actually starts a game there's nearly
800 people playing at least hopefully
most of them are people I know at some
point the pairings close and if it
starts a game it's probably not going to
be counting for the tournament if it
doesn't start a game I'll have to find a
different way of starting a game I mean
maybe I can just leave the tournament so
I don't want to wait chest with Kris is
streaming I wonder is Lee chest
detecting my stream ever be we just it's
not what's going on maybe it takes a
moment hey I got a game ok let's play
you for I've been on an e4 streak these
days I think I'll play Knight f3 it's a
little bit concerning that it's not
detecting the stream to make sure that
I'm live let's just play a normal
Italian mix it up a little bit and
played this in a while and let's play c3
this is one of the like first openings I
played or that I learned in childhood
called the molar attack where instead of
going for like kind of slower t3 I'll be
going for early d4 d6
I don't think is that great because d4
is strong
usually the main line is 906 hello to
people in the chat hello the number pad
do either Bansky moobot hello belgium
novice jaxtr the pro okay let's take and
now the bishop has to move like bishop
b6 is normal I remember there's some
idea where like it makes sense for a
white to play Bishop b5 but I think I'm
happy like keeping my Bishop attacking
f7 I could consider my g5 are the way I
could on my g5 there's mine age six then
d4 is weak so what to do I know why does
better but it's a question how to
maximize advantage maybe just Knight c3
and Bishop g4 Bishop e3 okay
93 is flexible move I think there's some
possibility like he'll play Bishop g4
I'll play Bishop e3 and then if he takes
I take back with pawn and I'll have
double pawns but very strong Center and
then in that case an open G file as well
so that would be nice
the nice thing about like having pawns
like this especially without like having
an e5 fun is that like I can consider
various ways to control even more space
there's a ladybug crawling up the window
but it's on the outside of the window so
I'm safe so 9 a5 he's attacking the
bishop I only actually have to defend
because I would have some Queenie
forecheck but I should probably defend I
could play it should be 5 Bishop d7 I
don't want to trade off this amazing
bishop so let's just play this at some
point I'll play maybe I'll fight b4
maybe I'll play like d5 and then b4 and
then the light is trapped it's a strong
possibility hello to more people
grey Hatter thanks for the bits not song
MTV this is a the daily rapid arena it's
a popular tournament but they'd just
finished the clock right into 0 so this
game won't count for any like tournament
points okay I'm gonna play Bishop III
hello to be x17 something-something
Origen twitch doesn't get the title I
don't really get the title either I was
trying to think of words that rhyme and
then somehow I made a title Keith
Patrick saying we need some subs in here
well Keith Patrick is a sub or is he no
he's a cheer is that it's one of the top
tier is actually okay nine of six so can
i I mean I want to go for d5 when he
trades bishops that's the one rule when
you have more space you shouldn't trade
if it's not necessary if it's not
winning anything I'm
to play Queen a forecheck than Queen d7
I played b4 there's a knight c6 seems
like like there should be some kind of
tactic somewhere the problem is I could
spend all my time looking for tactics
and then not find anything and then just
be low on time maybe I'll just play h3
let's play h3 and if Bishop takes f3 I'm
probably going to take back with pawn
because I want to I want to have a good
center and I want the open G file to
attack along so the tension is not being
relieved Queen a for Queen d7 Bishop e5
c6
there should be two way that might be
possible I'm gonna do it Queen a for
trusting my intuition the idea is now
that I don't think h3 Bishop h5 really
affected anything if you play c6 I trap
the Knights if he plays Queen d7 I play
Bishop e5 if he ever plays knight c6 I
of d5 so if Queen d7 Bishop e5 c6 then I
go back and then I'm threatening before
and I don't know if you can stop before
I guess you could play c5 but then I go
back to b5 and if he goes to c6 I have T
five and a six doesn't do anything
because they're gonna pin on the a file
and if you take so I just take back and
I still get my G file I've come to learn
that like when I post these things on
YouTube it the the thumbnail is usually
just the
whatever a moment has the most arrows so
this will probably be the YouTube
thumbnail if I do put this on YouTube
but for now let's play this should be
five yeah that was a bit excessive with
arrows I apologize for people who might
be overwhelmed okay like there's two
moves okay so you play c6 I'm playing
Bishop e2 because it feels more solid
because I could play Bishop d3 let's
play Bishop d3 just doing making sure
this is covered hey thanks for the saw
of compass Ringling appreciate it
okay so b4 is on its way
what does he do you can't play c5 you
could try and control the c-4 square
maybe he'll play this but then I play d5
and hit the Queen and then later play b4
this is a nice situation to be in
because he can't really move either pong
we'll see what he comes up with in the
meantime I can I can interact with the
chat oh okay he takes well it's still
the same predicament well I play viewers
um yeah probably if I have time I
already have a few pending challenges
such a rank difference feels like David
versus Goliath
who's Goliath he's ranked higher than me
he's or lower than I don't know 460 and
I'm 563 I feel like that okay the
ratings are probably more relevant so he
plays queenie 6 okay so this is a best
try so b4 night c4 doesn't need too much
but d5 there's d5 Queen e5 and I can't
play b4 because this is hanging so d5
Queenie five probably f4 Queen age 5 and
then b4 wait and he has Queen f3 this is
complicated and I'm gonna I'm getting
low on time but if I play d5 he goes to
h5 maybe I just throw in Bishop e2 I
just want to win material so if I win
material then things will be much easier
so sometimes situations like this when
you're on the verge of winning material
you just want to be cautious and
controlled thanks for the comment
Frosty's 42 and hello elastic cold
junior it's been a while
is it better to learn by playing online
or classic over the board chess depends
on how you learn best everyone's
different
it depends what your goals are - I'm at
a point where it doesn't really make a
difference if it's physical board or
digital board
it's just chess I know like when people
are first starting out of it it's
there's sometimes preferences one way or
the other
okay so beef or just making sure
I'm looking for tricks for black but I
don't see anything I was thinking like
he could take that then he would like to
play b5 then I just take with Queen okay
so life is good and the G file is open
so maybe I'll have some attack later and
black still under pressure cuz like
these pawns are falling apart if he
takes here or I take here my thread is
just to take and if he takes back the
night again when d5 and win the queen so
he'll probably castle hey it's bits BX
17
yay subs I guess we have yeah we have
one new sub
okay so castling now I don't think I
want to take because then he gets C file
action if I play rook g1 humans this
pawn I probably don't care about but I
kind of do I mean I'm up a piece I can
do anything really just as long as I
move quickly enough I'm not liking f2
idea being I want this rook to come to
g1 and then maybe someday I'll double up
just leaving the tension between the the
Queen side pawns queenie southern he
wants to play queen e5
mmm okay let's just take a free pawn if
Queenie five I'll probably play 95 if we
trade a few times I take up a b5 when am
i heading to London in like a week and a
half coming up I have to to figure out
more logistics is there anyone else like
that we'll be in London during World
Championships it's pretty historic event
he wants to play a night cheat or queen
g3 so let's play let's play rook a g1 if
Queen B - there's Bishop e2 I wonder if
I can get the so-called and the stages
mates
we're like 97 is playing I sack the
Queen on h7 and then I bring the rook in
to meet along the H file that might be
hard to accomplish but that's kind of
the goal here I'll start with 97 I'm not
gonna take the rook though even though
it's more free material let's take here
first hitting the night because now the
goal is to set up this mating idea
before he Flags but that's an annoying
move because now my knight has to move
away yeah maybe I won't get what I what
I'm most desiring I'll just take the
Knights and then I'll get this over with
let's play
g5 will double up mariel asks how many
norms am i away from GM I'm the same
number of norms that most people are
away from GM I'm three norms away I am I
don't even have the rating requirements
so it's far away I've I've accepted the
fact that I might never become a
grandmaster and I'm content with that so
I'm putting a lot more energy into
teaching these days rather than playing
but I I still will be competing some
tournaments coming up in Australia so
that feet should be nice let's take the
rook and go after a g7 and he's staying
alive kind of I'm still you're a hero
that's nice it's still our hero even
better
okay let's trap a rook
mmm let's take a look
yeah tough game I don't think I did
anything too special
I just controlled the center I trap
tonight I guess the most special thing
was this moment maybe I could have done
it and move sooner I should have played
a queen a4 first but this calculation
was nice
hey it sums I saw a ninja ninja had a
sub but now wait
Keith Patrick Keith Patrick like join
the chat saying they're like where are
the subs or something and now there's a
lot more subs welcome to all the new
subs I would try and like read the names
off but there's just so many Wow
so generous well congratulations guys
you have access to emotes you have your
sub badge I don't know if there's more
to talk about in this game maybe it was
a nice sum I was nice one of these
puzzle sequences like queynte for Bishop
e5 and Bishop back and then d4 comes up